let two plus three X to the 12 I'm gonna
start writing this down
let two x plus three to the 12 equal and
then they start giving you this Sigma
notation okay
oh sorry 2 are 2 plus 3x I have the
extra spot thank you two plus three X to
the power of 12 equal 2 and then they
stay at expansion here but in terms of
Sigma notation because I don't really
want to say all 13 terms here would I
know how how predictable they will be so
I'm going to start at term 0 I'm going
to go all the way up to 12 and that as
we've seen before and we reviewed this
morning the binomial expansion will have
sort of two components but here no sort
of collapse it down a little bit so they
call everything like these numbers here
right which has the binomial coefficient
in it but also has these numbers kind of
collapsed inside and simplified they
call all of that T of K T sub subscript
K okay and then there will be some power
of X involved okay so when we talk about
the greatest coefficient what we're
really interested in is this guy here
okay that's what we're interested in now
because they're starting us off easy
they have actually told us what T of K
is but if you have a look at it let's
write it down together because we're
going to need it in a second if you have
a look at it it's not that difficult to
realize what that is because when you're
doing the normal general term right
you have the binomial coefficient there
it is right and then you have some
number of these and some number of these
okay well if this is just the
coefficient part then I'm just ignoring
the X does that make sense well that
again this is just the coefficient so
I'm just ignoring the produ rules I'm
just looking at the 2 and the 3 and this
guy here is also a lot of her dear old
ok so you can see the rest of it there 2
times talk to power 12 to the K 12 minus
K and then there's a component with the
threes okay . right so this this little
probably here this is what we're
interested in okay and we need to also
as you'll see later on we need to know
what this is in terms of factorial
notation because we're gonna have to do
some
cancelling out here okay so let me
explain why pot Hey we begin by saying
write down expressions for this
coefficient K the K coefficient and also
the k plus one coefficient but the next
one after this one okay
now you might say well you mean that
you've already written down an
expression it's like yes but in order to
work with this thing we want to have
this and the next term interact with
each other I need to write this down all
in terms of factorial so that's the only
part that needs extra work for this T
sub K so I'm going to say T sub K equals
all right 12 choose K it's a fraction
right what's on the top do you remember
what factorial n factorial in this case
the N is 12 so I'm just gonna write 12
factorial on the bottom there's those
two factorials that are going to combine
so there's going to be K factorial and
what's the other one the one of the
brackets talked about is get very good
okay so there's the 12 choose K there
the tall CK and then the rest of it you
can't do very much to simplify it right
there's going to be the twos however
many you get and then there will also be
the threes however many you get okay so
this is the case coefficient right here
what about the next one the k plus one
coefficient well all I need to do you
just have to be careful when you do it
because it happens so many times is you
have to look at every time that K
appears and make it advance one okay so
if we have a look at the 12 CK business
you've got 12 factorial still hanging
out there on the top but instead of K
factorial I'm gonna have was the next
one over right sort of BK plus 1
factorial like so now after that I've
still got some other stuff on the bottom
here this gets bigger by 1 this will get
smaller by one yeah so this is not gonna
be 12 by this K factorial it'll be 11
minus K if you wanted you don't have to
write this if you wanted you could write
this as 12 minus k plus 1 factorial I
would be okay with that you're gonna get
the same answer
okay but I'm gonna just give a quick
caution
this is a really quick way to tie
yourself in knots right because there
are 70 brackets this is kind of one of
those places where it's easily easy to
fall into death by algebra you just miss
like a bracket or you miss an
exclamation mark or so that and then you
wonder why all the Hill working is wrong
okay so that's the first thing I will
say about that
the second thing is I want you to know
how factorials work right when you think
about like say these guys here okay each
of the coefficients will be what do we
got for C 0 for C 1 for C 2 and so on
right what are they in factorial
notation well the first one we for
factorial on 0 factorial 4 factorial
which is just 1 right you remember this
NC 0 no matter what it is we'll give you
cats or carrots or 1 right which is why
every end of Pascal strangles like that
when you have a look at the next one
this guy here right the top is still the
same 4 factorial but what will happen to
your denominator well one of them will
get bigger and then the other one will
get smaller and you can see here right
see how 4 factorial has 3 factorial
inside it right there's going to be 4
times 3 times 2 times white here here's
3 times 2 times 1
they just cancel which leaves you with 4
right so if you can see what is
happening rather than just crunching the
algebra you will have a better chance at
success here right so this one gets
bigger this one gets smaller I'm going
to go directly to writing 11 minus K
factorial right same deal here right see
how these powers one of them will get
bigger you get more and more and more of
them and then one will get smaller so
I'm gonna write here this one is clearly
the one that gets smaller it starts at
12 and it's going to climb down so I'm
gonna write that as 11 minus K it's
gotten one smaller and then this guy
over here it gets one bigger okay right
so there is my expression for the cake
coefficient and the k plus one
coefficient